the First Amendment guarantees freedoms
concerning religion expression assembly
and the rights of petitions it
guarantees freedom of expression by
prohibiting Congress from restricting
the press or the rights of individuals
to speak freely unless like people say
something that you really disagree with
then the whole thing is off for reasons
that are totally self-explanatory like
if someone says something that's really
unpopular or SuperDuper offensive then a
mandated safe space where people are
banned is obviously necessary because
some people can really be turd nuggets
also I think it's like super important
here to carve out a section for hate
speech which naturally shouldn't be
allowed but I've only got so much space
here on this parchment so I'll leave it
up to you to define it but I can say
that it's pretty much only applies to
straight white men you've totally got to
check that privilege bro also I want to
take this opportunity to specifically
address freedom of speech as it relates
toward feminists ladies consider
yourselves exempt for reasons that are
self-explanatory naturally the same goes
for college students which brings me to
my next point is freedom of speech
allowed on campus specifically public
universities now this is a gray area but
the general rule of thumb here is go
with your gut
I could write this more specifically but
I trust you can handle it you've reached
the world of higher learning after all
hashtag black lives matter as for
freedom of the press obviously that
comes with some caveats firstly like my
next amendment and muskets this one only
applies to quill and parchments I'm not
too worried as I'm pretty sure there's
our set information delivery mechanism
from here on out what else could there
be going back to carrier pigeons get out
of here
cut it out I think it goes without
saying the press can't be allowed to
marginalize minorities now this is
something where I want to be crystal
clear by marginalized I mean saying
anything that could be deemed offensive
and by minorities I mean whatever group
is really super mad that day
example maybe there's like a guy who'd
rather be a chick but he still has a
John Thomas so members of the press are
all like hey but you were still a guy
yesterday and we can still see your
penis through your knickers totally
unacceptable for reasons that are
self-explanatory also make sure that the
citizens exercising free speech on
campus are diverse ly represented
through the proscribed minority quotas
I'll include the specific numbers in
another document somewhere around here
trigger warning none of these quotas
apply to those damn Orientals for
reasons that are self-explanatory but
the real takeaway here the important
part to remember is that freedom of
speech only applies to certain people at
certain times provided there's no
possibility of offence to anyone else
for reasons that are totally
self-explanatory
the rights of the people to keep and
bear arms shall not be infringed unless
like guns get way more advanced than
today because this thing is totally
about hunting you guys I'm super serious